I don't want to make anyone I interview
with bad I don't want to make anyone who
washes us feel bad it's just such an
intimate thing volvo volvo volvo hard to
breathe what do you think it's this
weekend is gonna be like I would expect
crying maybe even nudity and maybe even
touching oneself so are you alone in
this Jo oh yeah hello I'm Merle and
today I'm going to be airing my largest
and security on the Internet
this is something that I've never really
talked about it's going to be an
experience for all of us okay I'm gonna
do that again I'll do a happy one I was
a really naked kid growing up and I
loved to be naked I would run around the
house naked
so my mom was super body-positive and
she always would encouraged me as a
little girl to take a mirror and go
explore you know go look at yourself and
I would do that the first thought was
like cool this is me this is what this
is somewhere over time I would look at
myself and I think and I different am I
the only one who looks like this am I
the only one who feels this way in
photos online or in pornography I would
see what I thought was the normal vulva
that was very neat hairless pink no
drama like a line and I don't know about
you but I have way more going on down
there you know what I did to try to find
out if I was normal and if my body was
normal I went on the Internet
I remember typing in what does a normal
vagina look like
it really did not help labiaplasty is
actually one of the fastest growing
cosmetic procedures and out of all
cosmetic surgery there's even reports
that girls as young as nine years old or
inquiring about getting labiaplasty and
changing their bodies because they feel
like they're not normal this led me to
think who wrote the rule book on what is
normal
how how is this happening and nobody's
talking about it so I decided I should
go talk to a surgeon labiaplasty has
been around just for a few decades the
first report in the medical literature
was about in the early 80s of course
there have been other forms of
labiaplasty just in terms of cultural
you know female circumcision or gentle
mutilations usually when people just say
labiaplasty they're referring to the
labia minora and though that's the inner
leaflet of lips and it's it's the
thinner tissue that tends to protrude if
there's any issue I mean what issue is
there I see patients sometimes where the
labia minora is longer or asymmetrical
and it bothers them those are patients
that we can fix her labia surgically but
it's not recommended unless it bothers
them so I actually tend to see patients
that are a little bit younger so
patients who are teenagers are either
brought in by their parents usually
their mom parents especially the mothers
are actually very supportive of their
daughters I do notice that usually it's
that the patients or the daughters are
more nervous because they're younger
they've never had any type of surgery
and you're talking about surgery in your
genital area so it's an area that
they're already not very comfortable
with they're not very experienced with
and they can it can get patients pretty
nervous
labiaplasty is not a benign procedure in
the wrong hands patients can have scar
tissue formation they can have chronic
pain and their sensitivity in that area
can be affected there's always risk of
bleeding there's risk of infection and
certain types of labiaplasty patients
are at risk of the suture opening up
some possible complications of the
Librium plasti include of course having
asymmetry at the end I mean the goal is
to make sure that your labia are
symmetric and aesthetically pleasing as
possible I would consider a normal or
average appearing vulva to be one where
the labia minora do not protrude past
the labia majora or if they do protrude
it's just slightly you know less than a
centimeter if you're below four
centimeters it's not considered like
hypertrophy like there's a deformity but
you can still get it done I in my
practice is 18 but I just did it in a
fifteen year old I'm not crying
I get nervous when I think about like
young girls hearing that there's like
some kind of a standard or some kind of
irregular or a normal when it doesn't
feel like that's anybody's position to
take I just I don't like the idea that
people are gonna watch this and feel the
way that I feel right now
I have very conflicting feelings on
labiaplasty I'm not here to tell anyone
what to do with their body but I don't
think it's something that should be
taken lightly and for me I want to try
to do it
the homeopathic way and learn to embrace
what I've got so that led me to go to a
weekend immersive experience with Pamela
Matson
okay I'm already blushing I'm nervous I
want to ask you how you feel about Amy
doing this video and be me going on this
retreat where I think want to be naked a
lot with a lot of women I could tell you
as much as possible how beautiful I
think you are but of course that the
other day you know it's a mindset that
if it was so easily fixable just by
someone else's words then it would be
but I know what some of that has to
click in your own head are you scared of
people I think I'm weird and now you're
dating me
I want you because of it we can talk
about sex
all we want but sometimes you have to
get in there and feel our bodies
hey I'm Pamela Matson and I am a
sexuality educator for women women are
taught from their first breath to be
frightened of their bodies we are
covered up our bodies are talked about
women are cultured into body
disconnection so we don't really get to
see other women's vulvas so we have no
idea what a normal Volta is so here's
the truth there is no normal Volvo even
Ebola there are no two vulvas that are
alike you have big inner labia and small
inner labia and big clits and small
clips and you come in all different
colors it's not amazing and we think
there's only one kind of vulva because
we're only showed the one in the little
girly magazine where some man decided
that was the perfect vulva my favorite
story is I was in fertility being at a
dinner with reproductive endocrinologist
someone was showing off about his new
really fabulous labor plasti program
that he had and I looked at him and said
so why are you doing that like what what
what is the reasoning behind cutting off
women's inner labia so he said to me
with a very straight face well women
with large in your labias are
uncomfortable wearing blue jeans so
functional reasons for labiaplasty could
be that the patient is
having pain they feel uncomfortable they
can even have some discomfort just based
off with the type of clothes that they
wear like if they wear an underwear or
tight-fitting clothes during activities
such as having sex with sports you know
wow really so like that would be like do
they come in and have your shorts so
that they can fit better in their blue
jeans and so they could ride their
bicycle better so like fake news perfect
vulva that looks this way or that way is
fake news perfect
Balthus that is your vulva that's the
truth
we need more sex education and not just
about reproductive health but what is
sexual health different changes that go
on in different ages in our life and
then also how to talk about it how do we
talk about what's going on with us
sexually and normalize it so when you're
in high school what they teach you is
that you have sex basically you're gonna
get a disease die or get pregnant nobody
ever talks about pleasure and you
remember the way they detect female
reproductive system it's you know the
chart it kind of looks like Lucifer's
goat which is like pretty rock and roll
but for me there was no education on the
external parts of female genitalia I
don't have a vulva model though I only
have the vagina is that okay okay
most doctors will not ask about sex or
about sexual and at like they won't
and and they're uncomfortable I think
the reality is most adults the people
who are teaching kids are not
comfortable with sexuality themselves so
the vulva is actually the external
genitalia for female bodies and that can
include the clitoris the labia minora
majora the vulva has more involved a
female pleasure the vagina is actually
the internal genitalia it's also
referred to as the birth canal if you
don't learn your vulva anatomy in high
school what you learn about in high
school is not to show you vulva to
anybody including yourself we judge our
beauty or sexuality our hotness through
the eyes of other people we don't
actually feel it inside ourselves so
what we're going to be doing over these
next few days is some reclamation and
what we're just going to be asking you
to do is receive how does it feel as a
woman just to be adored to have present
to have touch given to you and what
happens to your body when you can simply
be focused on that you don't trust your
body if you're hiding your body if
you're hiding your sexuality how are you
gonna be a leader in your life I was
feeling really empowered and curious
really curious I was like okay okay wait
wait wait I have never heard people
think of sex this way does this mean
that there's like an area of the world
where people are trying to lift women
huh in this way like what cool I think I
might can I actually ask you a couple of
questions on camera yeah of course yeah
bring it on if we're allowed to grow up
learning about the pleasure of being a
woman if we're allowed to grow up loving
our bodies those are the young women
that grow up to be the president why is
this so uncomfortable for me like why is
this you know why is this hard to talk
about we've heard this as a private part
we've heard this as a dirty part
we've heard messages like cover this
don't show and we don't really have a
relationship with our goal in the words
for some people are embarrassing
so the vulva is the all the vagina
they just yeah like a friendly word or
the vulva can be for the vault lock
that's the hard word vulva vagina I
should say okay so for them I should
[ __ ] or shade which I say the vulva
vagina vulva vulva female genital area
or I'll just say both yeah vault as a
clinician I don't think I heard vulva
until I was in graduate school already
studying to be a sex therapist we are
always worried that we are taking too
long
and that's because we run on a
patriarchal model of the sexual
experience
we carry generations of shame that we've
just been hearing these messages and
taught these messages so when we
liberate ourselves what changing
most women are cheated out of their
arousal men aren't trained in it women
don't have a clue you need between 15
minutes and 45 minutes or an hour just
to get warmed up you're worried about
how you taste you worry about how you
smell it can be so startling when you
finally realize that your body is
beautiful and your sexuality is
beautiful and that you wasted all these
months perhaps all these years on shame
it's that moment of oh my god why did I
let this go by what brought me to this
whole thing was like a deep insecurity
with how I look and I was like I don't
and like that's what brought me here and
that's the whole videos about it was
like getting to know your vulva
understanding what a vulva is that that
kind of was my pathway to arousal by
like conquering that I'm like wow
there's so much out there like you know
that whole world yeah that's crazy yeah
I just wanna like pause because it's
like such a big deal and I can like feel
the emotion
yeah yeah I never liked that first I
think I carry a lot of trauma there too
so it's just like always like a really
unsafe place most women have experienced
some sort of trauma at some point in
their life big t trauma a little T
trauma some sort of experience that
wasn't great if you've experienced
trauma in your body connecting with your
body can kind of be like returning to
the scene of the crime in a way like
I've had sexual experiences where not
only did I not get what I want
I've had things taken from me and that
doesn't leave your body your body
remembers things that your mind will let
go of and this was another reason it was
so terrifying to connect my body because
I have so many scary memories there I've
been celebrated over by people I don't
want to be thinking about me I don't
want to be touching me
and this felt like an opportunity to
reclaim that my body is just for myself
hard to breathe so we could be doing low
dose of meditation
[Music]
ladies you are so powerful around with
it that connection that kind of brings
it back down right also like just kind
of feel like you're not alone and like
not everybody that's the same journey I
was big but it's just exciting and
obviously very emotional but I strolled
but for a really long time it feels and
a good new beginning and like giving
permission to take it on women who are
embodied I dangerous and that's why the
culture works really hard to shame us
and keep us small when you give yourself
permission you enroll people into your
lives when you explain what you're doing
when you share what you're doing when
you don't make what you're doing
shameful and you don't hide and then
guess what you permission other women
she permission that I permission and new
permission and then we're all
permissions and then we become beautiful
receivers wherever you are in your
relationship to your body to your
sexuality whatever you're feeling you're
not alone I think we need to stop
waiting for permission to love ourselves
something pinless said that really stuck
with me was bodies are beautiful when
bodies are embodied and
that's for everyone I feel unstoppable
now I'm just I'm really excited to see
where this takes me
[Music]
you